empty Max versus M2 Ultra Max studio is
it worth spending an extra two thousand
dollars double the price to get the M2
Ultra well I ran a ton of real world
benchmarks and I might give you guys all
of those results to show you which one
you should buy depending on what you do
first off the ultra is heavy you gotta
set the sucker down to hold it to your
hands that is because when we took it
apart we saw that it has a copper cooler
inside of there that weighs a lot more
than the aluminum one now also talk
about fan noise and temperatures in just
a bit now on the outside these things
look identical but if you get the M2
Ultra the front two ports here turn into
Thunderbolt instead of standard USB type
c so that is a benefit if you want a lot
of ports but with that you can also
connect eight displays instead of five
with the M2 Max now with that if you
have something high resolution like an
8K that still gives you more ability
have other high-res displays where that
is where the M2 Max can be a little bit
limited the SSD speeds are also a lot
faster on the M1 Ultra model because it
comes standard with a one terabyte
whereas for two grand you have 512 but
if you spend an extra 200 bucks you also
get that speed which is really nice with
that the M2 Ultra comes with 64 gigs of
RAM standard you have to have that much
whereas with the two thousand dollar
model we have 32 gigs that you can
upgrade but overall the ultra supports
double the RAM for two grand you get a
12 core processor but the ultra comes
with a 24 core it's exactly double so
you'd expect to get double the CPU
performance well in geekbench if we take
a look at single core I actually got a
lower score on the ultra than on the max
for some reason and then looking at
multi-core performance we have 14 600
compared to twenty thousand seven
hundred and if you can do the math that
is not double that is actually roughly
42 percent more performance because at
least in these kind of tasks it's not
scaling linearly testing out speedometer
2.0 for web browsing performance you see
that the speed is the same because a lot
of this is single core tasks and they
are very similar but then testing out
web-based applications like figma this
is created for us by 500 designs one of
the best studios in La smoothness is
identical with both of these systems and
then when I selected 12 of these high
resolution web pages and exported them
to times where identical for both of
these once again so if you use web-based
applications don't expect a big
difference between these systems you
could save the money in terms of
Graphics we have 30 cores compared to
60. once again double the core counts
now both of these can be upgraded to
have the unbined chip with the Mt Max
that costs you 200 bucks but with the M2
Ultra that is a 1 000 upgrade that is
crazy now in this video I'm just going
off of the base specs I have other
videos that show there's differences
between the other configurations but
looking at geekbench 6's metal score we
have slightly better scaling than CPU
but once again it's only about a 45
difference not a doubling of performance
now with that said the M2 Ultra has much
better scaling than the M1 Ultra and
you'll see in some of these upcoming
tests but it is still not perfect in
3dmark's Wildlife extreme which is a
gaming Benchmark here we see about a 48
difference so yeah it's there but the
bang for the buck is definitely going
down if you want to play the Metal based
applications and games pushing the CPUs
to their limits in Cinemax R23 this is
where we start to see a much bigger
proper difference of almost 92 percent
for 13 and a half thousand compared to
almost twenty eight thousand so if your
program can push the CPU all of the
course to their limits you'll see that
difference now this is where I want to
take a look at the cooling because this
is where we get the most heat now the M2
Ultra ran at 85 degrees with the fans
completely idle whereas the M2 Max ran
at 69 degrees also idle now I mentioned
that the cooler is made out of aluminum
it is not as nice as the copper cooler
also weighs a lot lot less but because
the M2 Max has half the cores has a lot
less wattage almost half the wattage it
actually runs cooler completely idle and
both these run completely silent so
don't worry about temperatures or fan
noise now for the coders out there we
ran our xcode Benchmark and here I
expected to have a pretty good
difference now for those of you guys
that run Logic the M2 Ultra can handle
320 tracks in our new logic pro
Benchmark you guys can check that out
compared to
181 so if you need the most ultimate
performance for a lot of plugins a lot
of tracks while the ultra will give you
that and the extra Raymond here helps as
well now as far as blender for 3D
rendering I tested out the BMW test
first and it flies on the M2 Ultra it
took just 13 seconds compared to 21. so
that's not perfect scaling but we're
getting there and then in the tougher
party tug test here we had 33 seconds
compared to a minute and four that is
almost perfect scaling and that is where
the M2 Ultra is much better than the M1
Ultra they did a great job with the
memory and the controller is in here so
if you're doing 3D rendering you
absolutely should get the ultra now as
far as photo editing using Lightroom
classic that will harness all the CPU
and the GPU performance the M2 Ultra was
literally twice as fast in this test
everything was useful and it just
screams now this is where I need to talk
to you guys about how much performance
do you actually need the M2 Max is
already about twice as powerful as my
fifteen thousand dollar Intel Mac Pro
this thing is super fast so I would say
for a lot of people the performance is
more than enough so just because the M2
Ultra is so much faster that doesn't
mean that you need it unless you're
exporting thousands of photos a day just
because the regular editing performance
is very similar between these and in
Photoshop running a panorama here the
performance is double so it just once
again shows if the program can harness
it you will get killer scaling and now
getting into video editing stabilizing a
one minute 4K clip that time was the
same and that's because a lot of that
time is literally just initializing and
finishing the stabilization process and
then exporting a standard five minute 4K
project with effects you guys see that
the M2 Ultra is really fast and that is
because it has double the encoders for
video and with speeds like this a 20
minute project will take just over two
minutes to export you don't even have
time to go get some coffee or something
else it is crazy fast and now getting
into something a little tougher we have
4K prores raw encoding into prores that
is graded and here the difference is not
double it is literally 30 seconds
compared to 40 insanely fast for a five
minute project on both and that is
because both of these do have prores
decoders and encoders the M2 Ultra does
have double but because it is so
insanely fast already well you don't get
the full benefit here another thing that
was weird for me was red AK raw both of
these played back perfectly which was a
first for me and as far as exporting
these the M2 Ultra was just slightly
faster now I don't know if there are
other bottlenecks maybe it's Red's
plugin now that is being a limitation
here we obviously have more graphics
performance that's mostly Graphics based
a little bit CPU based but if you edit
with this footage at least for now the
difference is negligible now I also
denoise 4K Blackmagic raw and DaVinci
Resolve and this has both spatial and
temporal and even the M2 Max was able to
play back at a perfect 24 frames per
second which was the first for a Mac now
the M2 Ultra has a little bit of
overhead but it's just a tiny bit more
not much at all so once again either
it's some kind of limitation I don't
know what's going on but even for this
crazy tough task
um they are closer than I would expect
effect now with that said should you
spend the extra two thousand dollars and
I'll be honest with you guys for me
personally I would say no because
sometimes you could wait a little bit
longer because it's already incredibly
fast and other times the results were
quite similar and the scaling in a lot
of things was not perfect so if you need
something specific like the Photoshop
and Lightroom insane performance or
super fast exports for standard footage
I would say maybe it would be worth it I
think the main way it would be worth it
is for those that use blender because
Macs are already behind windows and
video based systems but spending twice
the money even though scaling is a
better time around at this time around
it is just a hard sell so for us we are
going to stick to the M2 Max version now
if you guys want to see how the Mac
Studio compares to the M2 Pro Mac Mini I
have that video right there we also have
another great video and I'll do a video
comparing the bin versus unbend you guys
can click that Circle above to see it
but let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below